bro give him a [ __ ] Medal of Honor
yeah let's give him a reward he doesn't
get the money he lost right purple heart
give him a Ramen for the rest of his
time yeah bro Philip was commissary was
the top Ramen yeah
[Music]
you're gonna think this story is awesome
but that's not the correct feeling okay
be be mad at this guy
as much as you want to DAP them up don't
do it now I just want to dab him up even
though there's a guy angrily in Georgia
uh he's CR he's in jail right okay
somehow manages to pull an 11 million
dollar Heist from prison that's pretty
cool using nothing more than a smuggled
phone
11 million dollars a heist you said
smuggled through who did he Heist from
he heisted from um hoisted from
billionaire Sydney Kimmel okay who was
responsible for funding a lot of
different projects such as crazy Rich
Asians oh yeah he's from jail yeah he's
a Hollywood Tycoon he got into his uh
bank account
and uh I guess he stole his identity at
some point prior to going to jail and I
I don't know how he even did this but
um he managed to convince the Charles
Schwab Bank that he was that guy
with his paid phone calls from the
[ __ ] jail dude
stolen driver's license and a and a uh a
utility bill
that was like taken so he managed to do
that and moved 11 million out of his
bank account used those to and he
cleaned them up by buying gold coins
with all that money takes the gold coins
and then uh
convert some of those into other cash
and then buys uh buys a house
by the commissary oh yeah he buys it out
so he just has 11 million in credit for
the jail hey yo why your boy get Top
Ramen every day
because that's living dude you buy
cigarettes you can train with people
you're [ __ ] living dude that's so
crazy that would be like it's so good
and then it's just bad again
he buys one house just to be the top G
in cell block a he buy he buys one house
and he has 10 mil in the commissary dude
that isn't that crazy that you did that
11 million bro he shouldn't get all of
it but he should get a little bit for
the credit well that was pretty that was
impressive so here's here's a good
question for you so what they couldn't
figure out is after he um bought that
house with that stolen money uh
authorities trying to figure out what to
do with it because
um
he bought it and what happens then does
they do they give the house back to the
guy or and the money goes back like I
would think they freeze they would put
some type of judgment on that house
there's been a couple situations where
like people owe for like fraud back
taxes or something like that the US
government will like put a piece of
paperwork on that on that property
saying this is like oh so it's almost
like freezing the entire house but
that's like when it's clear that the the
house now belongs to the government
correct but in this situation it's like
that money came from this other
billionaire so it's like hey billionaire
dude you kind of have like a new house
now that was just paid in gold right
it's like you still want it yeah yeah or
do you want the commissary
the house is under that the guy that was
in jail right that did the Ice no what's
that technically probably well no if
it's identity theft Oh no just to pull
the money so you probably put the name
did he put that name in his actual or
the house in his actual name or in the
see if that is and they can't be like
hey you got a new house because it's not
in there then maybe it's just insurance
that the billionaire gets back or some
[ __ ] you know what I mean yeah I don't
know because in in the art in both
articles I read they were trying to work
out what exactly happens to the home I
was in the US government would put some
type of like lean against the house
stating like this is there's a there's a
case on this does anything happen to you
if you were the um if you were the agent
in that sale and it went to a guy
fraudulently I think if you knew about
it yeah definitely
for sure like if I knew this guy was
like he pulled this money from something
that was illegal then what is it called
like coercion or oh yeah probably
something like that yeah do they but if
you honestly have no idea and you they
can't prove that you knew it then oh
then you got to keep the commission
right of course Double Jeopardy gold
coins baby it's already spent
so so if that's the expert money bought
a house from you that turns out all that
money stolen so they take it all back
but the commission you have you don't
have to give it back it's just is this
your money
yeah if you didn't know about I would
think yeah I don't know yeah I think you
get to keep it for sure yeah but if you
knew then they would probably I I think
it'd probably be worse it would probably
prosecute you yeah that's gonna be way
worse then you'd be an accessory because
you're part of the operation exactly so
he did have two people on the outside
that were a part of the operation that
were moving things for him and it was
like uh so in that case there's three
defendants so it's him and then two
other people that were doing that and uh
that's kind of Genius wait wouldn't that
be a little fishy because he's got to
sign paperwork to buy that house to be
like yeah I'm in jail right now I just
send the paperwork over I'd notarize it
like that that'd be a little bit did he
buy it under his name or was it a fake
identity and they're trying to see if it
might have been under the names of the
other two accomplices they don't know
for sure it doesn't say for sure who it
was but most likely it was under one of
them if he can't even be there is that
even possible like let's say you had a
fake identity fake ID and you bought a
house under that
like
if the if it's not under your real name
then can they take that from you well
there's like a form when you're in
escrow where you have to fill out it's
like a statement of information so like
they want to identify who you are so you
got your name birthplace birthday Social
Security number so you're gonna have to
come up with yeah like all fake yeah
exactly so a man's Jason Bourne though
you know what I mean so there's gonna be
a lot of stuff that you're gonna have to
come up with so it's super crazy because
it looks so easy that
um how he was able to get
that identity because he used a driver's
license a utility bill and then used
text now to call the bank and make it
look like he was calling from LA
but doesn't that seem like uh to move 11
million from the bank that's all they
really needed he said he's a billionaire
right yeah that's still a lot of [ __ ]
money that's like that's like the chase
uh agent on the other side looking at
all the zeros and be like you only want
to move this many zeros all right
unfortunately it's like moving eight
bucks from my account yeah yeah it's
like moving a couple hundred bucks
got it
yeah it's a it's a super crazy thing he
had two phones in his cell by the time
they like caught on to all this
happening
through the butt through the butt
through the butt that's not oh he's
already in I think like in this jail
alone they said that that in in uh one
year They confiscated like oh I've seen
him like on like rails and stuff it's
like all the people in prison like yeah
you ever seen prison dude yeah prison
Tick Tock is my favorite kind of tick
tock there's so many phones in jail yeah
bro they're they're chilling they're
going live in prison you know like how
they got white Wi-Fi yeah like what the
[ __ ] dude dude someone smuggled a router
foreign
ER they look like that I don't know if
that's true but they do they're like
little towers they're mini Towers oh and
then it like telescopes like a
lightsaber it doesn't pull up it's just
about like this this tall expandable
Wi-Fi router just to make sure you can
be compact when you travel with your
butt yeah dude dude yeah so this dude is
like pretty badass because he's uh
what's it look like I need to see this
man come on what do you go to jail for
he went in for an attempted robbery or
something but but then from jail he got
in trouble for ordering hits on people
from jail this reminds me of that movie
with Gerard Butler remember did he kill
somebody with a T-bone steak PS I Love
You No this is Law Abiding Citizen yeah
that [ __ ] is good it's called the
bouncing on track oh Traveler's Wife
it's exactly like that
movie good movie yeah he was he did uh
order a hit on his ex or something from
jail using one of his phones because
once they were investigating they were
investigating his phones finally thanks
to guards they found like all of his
past like operations that he was running
and they were like dude you you try to
kill someone dude imagine the respect
that the people working for him must
have had to in order for them to risk
just doing this for him while he's in
jail they probably respected the [ __ ]
out of him or something right the dude
is good he gets results look at that
he's a good guy he probably has Charisma
or something to uh yes good feng shui
people to listen to him in jail a good
puncture he's got 11 million he's
probably like here's one yeah
I got this plan it's gonna work no no
but they gotta believe him for them to
even I bet sometimes you don't need to
get certain people to believe you to do
stuff like that they'll just do it if
you if you're good enough a Salesman of
being like yo I gotta get and you'll get
paid that's how they described him so
that he was a good salesman they
described him as a guy that could con
you out of millions he calmed the
[ __ ] Charles Schwab you know and they
oh by the way Charles Schwab they are
also fully reimbursed Kim the full
amount that's tight see there's because
there's that insurance right it's pretty
much their fault yes well they didn't
want to lose the billion that they had
with them right
yeah
yeah yeah so they were saying um the
house was left vacant after the uh the
whole thing blew up and then they said
it's not been maintained and it's
rapidly deteriorating so they're saying
the judge might approve a motion where a
real estate agent will be authorized to
Market and sell the house but the
valuation has gone down since he bought
it because he hasn't been living in it
would you sell a house that went through
all that type of stuff yeah I would tell
it we had one in Arcadia that happened
and the guy owed the government like I
don't know if it was tax evasion or or
whatnot but like it was like us super I
wasn't Supreme Court but it was like one
of the core systems like you saw the
paperwork this guy owes x amount of
money so like was it a big case because
we know about that one big one
uh this was like a while back ago I
don't know how I forgot how much is but
um yeah government gets their money
first after the sale and then whatever's
left over if he doesn't owe anything
else then I guess they gotta keep it
damn all right so since Nick wants to
see this is the dude that's the dude and
then that's a Kimmel over here bro give
him a [ __ ] Medal of Honor yeah let's
give him a reward he doesn't get the
money he lost her purple heart give him
a Ramen for the rest of his time yeah
bro Philip was commissary was the top
Ramen yeah that's a that's a really like
your concept of stealing all that money
and just depositing it in your
commissary that's so funny what about
the rest of your symptoms you know how
they stay in prison for oh before I
think it's being extended but then uh I
don't know how what the initial uh thing
was but um looks like a nice dude I know
a guy that looks just like him and he's
actually it's like I know 50. it's one
of those things where like if this guy's
uh cleverness was just like pointed in a
different direction I think he can still
pivot bro I think I have faith I think
he this guy could turn his life around
Nick's inspired we didn't say how are
you gonna get baptized
it doesn't it doesn't say eventually
what what was the trigger to like find
out all this stuff was going on May
maybe um because it might have been the
house sale I think oh yeah the house
sale or like a large amount of money
being moved it's like hey let's
investigate this see if he [ __ ] laid
low yeah do my plan can you lay any
lower than being in jail yeah
[Music]